c'est pas de la publicité n'est une fête
news mais demain nutella coca cola ou
ricard pour ne pas les citer vont coûter
plus cher dans les supermarchés c'est
l'un des effets de la loi alimentation
qui entre en vigueur ce 1er février
alors un bref rappel cette loi elle est
censée permettre de mieux rémunérer les
agriculteurs et elle oblige donc les
grands distributeurs type carrefour ou
leclerc à les payer davantage mais le
système est complexe parce qu'il n'est
pas évident que le consomateur au final
s'ils retrouvent avant d'en parler je
vous propose d'écouter périco légasse
chroniqueur gastronomique à
l'hebdomadaire marianne est souvent
invité deux points de vue il défend
l'idée première des états généraux de
l'alimentation qui ont abouti à cette
loi on écoute on interdira la grande
distribution de faire des baisses des
prix massives sur certains produits
d'appel de grande consommation
parce qu'en fait on va dire la vérité et
c'est là où je suis content que les
grands distributeurs viennent s'exprimer
je dois voir monsieur michel edouard
leclerc à face de moi quand il faisait
baisser des prix
mais ne croyez pas qu'ils faisaient
cadeau aux consommateurs si il le riz le
facturer à un autre fournisseur
et le pire c'est que souvent pour vendre
une infamie aux ventes de la malbouffe
pas cher et dont on écrasait les prix
pour la vente en gros aux minces en
grande quantité eh bien on étrangle est
quelquefois un agriculteur lui avec ses
pommes avec ses pointes mons et pommes
de terre qui paient la différence michel
edouard leclerc auquel faisait allusion
périco légasse et bien lui aussi il a
réagi on les écoute tout de suite et
puis on parle de tout ça imaginez des
caissières des chefs de rayon qui vont
devoir répondre à des consommateurs
huawei la hausse du prix du riz car un
euro et demi c'est pour aider les
agriculteurs mais tout le monde va
croire que c'est de l'enfumage personne
n'est capable d'expliquer par quels
mécanismes de ruissellement cet argent
supposé gagner par les distributeurs ira
chez les éleveurs de lait marc andrey
parce qu'elles n'ont pas si on ne passe
pas ce qu'il y avait deux objectifs dans
la loi dans les états généraux de
l'alimentation il y avait un
effectivement fournir aux agriculteurs
venus
rémunération leur travail mais en avait
un deuxième qui était de réguler les
prix dans la grande distribution sans
lien aucun avec les agriculteurs pour
éviter en sorte que ce soit l'anarchie
totale comme c'est le cas depuis
quelques temps où on va voir des super
promos sur dépôt d'un litre de nutella
ou d'un kg nicholas tara donc il y avait
ces deux là sur le sol le ricard c'est
simplement ça mais là on a une comment
dire une une loi qui était qui partaient
d'un bon état d'esprit ou d'une bonne
volonté et qui est complètement perverti
c'est que maintenant vous entendez
gouvernement vous dire attendez on va
pas faire comme ça tout à fait en vérité
on demande du civisme aux grandes
surfaces et aux distributeurs et que de
répartir mieux leurs marges
donc ils peuvent continuer à garder des
prix bas sur sa main produits de grande
consommation mais si à côté il se
rattrape sur autre chose
simplement il faut que d'une manière
générale les la répartition des prix et
donc de la marge soit mieux répartie
sauf que là c'est la porte ouverte à
tout et n'importe quoi et en plus c'est
nonobstant les négociations
individuelles que telle centrale a pu
avoir avec tel entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire parce que le prix du
nutella c'est pas le même que vous allez
chez leclerc chez carrefour chez
monoprix chez auchan ou ailleurs ça
dépend aussi des conditions de
négociations qui ont été faites à un
moment donné et par rapport aux 6 à la
structure de consommation telles ou
telles conditions avec telle ou telle
telle ou telle distributeurs vous êtes
plutôt michel edouard leclerc ou plutôt
périco légasse ses joueurs périco
légasse travail de vous le dire mais je
suis content déjà qu'il parle je suis
content qu'il parle d'alimentation on
l'a beaucoup entendu parler d'autre
chose
il a pas tort sur ce point points le
deuxième point aussi c'est que la loi
est ce que ma qu'on fait c'est peut-être
voilà les images des émeutes de beauvais
du nutella des gens qui se sont rués
qu'on a un peu moqué sur les réseaux en
les appelant les gueux et en se moquant
un peu de cette frénésie qui voulait
acheter du nutella du voile à 2
le sucre ça cachait peut-être les jeunes
qui venaient ensuite et ça mc on l'a
compris et je pense qu'on lui fait pas
justice mais il a compris peut-être
avant c'était une de ses propres
promesses de campagne assez essentielle
ça a marché c'est ça le but et le bronze
de campagne en pensant que l'éditeur
soit un peu à rémunérer un petit peu
mieux ces cinq absents sauf que celles
qui ne marchent pas et leclerc se venge
un petit peu parce que oui il ya une
guerre entre les deux là c'est évident
jenny vous le côté quand même objectif
là aussi peut-être pas atteint mais de
lutter contre la malbouffe 2
ça doit pas être décrétée dans aux
essais je trouve ça très bien qu'on
interdise les promos à la chaîne la
vente au prix coûtant qui sont des
manières en distribution d'écraser
absolument lécousse et 2 et devant
vraiment des produits de très mauvaise
qualité en tout cas pour le qui sont
d'ailleurs sûrement addictif et c est
donc ça je sais très bien mais je pense
que c'est pas du tout suffisant pour les
problèmes des agriculteurs et de la haie
et c'est vrai qu'en france on a quand
même un problème avec la grande
distribution on est le pays d'europe où
il ya le plus de grandes surfaces
je rappelle que des députés lrm avait
proposé de faire un moratoire sur les
grandes surfaces et bercy a mis son veto
au nom de la liberté de commerce donc je
remarque voilà mais c'est pas là la
librairie base de retrait oui mais un
moratoire en tout cas on aurait su un
peu quelle était la situation où il faut
aller etc
je suis à une a encore qui se
construisent à moi j'en vois se
construire encore en province c'est pas
vrai qu'il y en a plus du tout qui se
construisent
certes il ya une crise des gros gros
hypermarchés et notamment dans les
villes un retour du commerce de petits
trots ximité dans les grandes métropoles
attention pas dans les villes
intermédiaires et ça c'est un vrai état
problème il donc ça il ya une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur le problème de la
grande distribution qui tue les petits
commerces qui a tué tous les centres
villes davids intermédiaires de cette
france périphérique dg des jeunes
justement et ça justement il ya aucune 0
réflexion là dessus sur établir voilà
les vrais des vraies perspectives
d'avenir pour sauver nos agriculteurs en
redonnant ainsi qu'aujourd'hui il ya les
circuits courts qui fonctionne bien et
qui sont de plus en plus qui marche de
plus en plus et la grande messe comme ça
il n'y a rien entre les deux est assez
c'est très politique
les agriculteurs juste un élément à la
réflexion afin de vous
nous donniez votre point de vue jacky
isabello je voyais c'est connu mais je
le rappelle la part du budget des
ménages consacrée à l'alimentation
elle est
en tendance laisse s étaient 35% du
budget ans dans les années 60 ce n'est
plus que 20 % la hausse il faut
peut-être se poser question défendez des
grands distributeurs puisque course on a
fait référence à vichy moi je vais dire
les grands distributeurs c'est un peu
l'air qui la république c'est à dire que
on l'aura dans les années mais c'est la
vie je dis que je les défends ce jeu ne
fait pas à moitié
non mais ce qu'il faut bien se rappeler
c'est que dans les années 70 à l'époque
de giscard le pouvoir en place et les
grands distributeurs ont fait une
alliance en dix ans on a besoin de vous
pour maîtriser l'inflation et donc on a
fait des échanges de ronds points contre
des grandes surfaces se sont organisés
pour maîtriser les prix c'est vrai que
les grands distributeurs ont eu un
travail absolument remarquable pour pour
juguler cette inflation qui était
vraiment une plaie pour le pays après
les gens y compris
ils y ont pris goût et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est assez facile de
l'ordre de leur taper dessus c'est
d'autant plus facile que un peu grisés
par leur hyper puissance se sont devenus
avec ses systèmes dits paire centrale à
l'intérieur chaque acheteur est devenu
pardon entre guillemets un véritable
salopards avec le petit patron et les pm
donc c'est vrai que entre d'un côté des
agriculteurs qui avec lens hyper
syndicats ont été un foutu de réformer
leur modèle parce que on sait très bien
que la politique agricole commune ça
fait quand même trente ans qu'on
explique à tout le monde qu'elle va
qu'elle va changer et donc encore une
fois on oppose des gens alors que c'est
un modèle qui est en train d'évoluer
je trouve que les grands distributeurs
comme souvent c'est une victime à sa
façon à ce que quand on achète tous
cette culpabilité le samedi ou avant
quand on allait avec notre caddie parce
qu'on leur tape dessus mais vous savez
il ya quelqu'un qui est le chantre un
peu de 2
de l'essence en france qui ait ce type
de jeux perdent l'anc et 40 millions de
consommateurs il vous dit vous pouvez
inventé tous les produits toutes les
innovations
la seule chose qui marche à la fin pour
le consommateur ces prix voilà une fois
que vous avez compris ça et bien
débrouillez-vous son marché tous les
samedis on peut payer assez peu de chair
aussi donc il ya des façons de faire il
ya des façons de vente directe de ce
fruit circus pour la révolution
je voudrais qu'ils nous laissent un tout
petit peu de temps pour parler de la lie
cigarettes et de donner quelques
réactions je sais que le sujet vous
passionne tous déjà la question twitter
est ce que la loi alimentation permettra
de mieux rémunérer les agriculteurs 78%
d'entre vous pensent que non brownie
taudis la loi ne paraît pas si complexe
que ça on croit au ruissellement
l'argent du consommateur qui réussit
elle régis coproducteur la question est
qui croient encore au ruissellement
efficace nicole les augmentations des
prix alimentaires ne vont pas arranger
les relations entre macro et les gilet
jaune c'est pas faux d'autant qu'il ya
d'autres augmentations dans le même
temps c'est l'électricité des péages
vous fait pas la liste marque vous la
connaissez anti mac nous dit je trouve
eugénie excellente dit tout de suite ma
part à joly quelques sous la main voilà
c'est dit aussi aux autres pertes
doivent être mais parfois hessische les
petits commerces meurent car ils
n'apportent pas de valeur ajoutée pour
acheter un savon made in china 30% plus
cher aux commerces du coin nous avons
nous n'avons aucune valeur ajoutée et 38
qu'il trouve très beau pendant que ça
viendra ça vire malakoff
s'il vous plaît faites rapport d'ici la
fin d'émission il vous reste deux
minutes vingt alors les cigarettes
vive la cigarette électronique pour
arrêter de fumer car elle serait plus
efficace que les chewing gum ou les
patchs c'est le résultat d'une étude en
principe sérieuse qui a été fait par une
université anglaise et qui est relayée
par le new england journal